yanick villedieu merci d'être avec nous
ça me fait le plus grand des plaisirs y
aller pourquoi s'intéresser quarante ans
plus tard au sida alors que les yeux de
la planète entière sont tournés vers la
coved 19 vers l'autre pandémie se passer
d'abord le
l'épidémie de sida la pandémie s'il
n'est pas terminé il ya encore entre 700
mille et un million de personnes qui
meurent du sida par année dans le monde
on oublie encore aujourd'hui il ya un
million et demi de nouvelles infections
est à 37 ou 38 millions de porteurs du
virus et on sait que quand on est
porteur du virus du sida on l'est pour
toujours donc l'épidémie 20 corps actuel
même si où la pandémie même si l'autre
pour d'amy a pris un peu la pris le
devant et c'est normal d'ailleurs l'eau
chose c'est que c'est une histoire
quarante ans une histoire importante
extraordinaire à une histoire tragique
avec tous les
dizaines de millions de morts que le
sida a fait que le virus a fait est
aussi une histoire de science de
recherche de médecine c'est une histoire
qui n'est pas comme les autres à une
maladie qui n'est pas comme les autres
dont elles n'étaient pas comme les
autres parce qu'elle touchait au départ
touche au départ des groupes très
particulier des homosexuels les
utilisateurs de drogues par voie
intraveineuse et hull g dans le drame
des hémophiles aussi et ces maladies qui
touchait le sens le sexe l'amour la mort
des jeunes qui mouraient normalement en
pleine forme qui mouraient dans des
conditions vraiment terrible donc il ya
eu cette maladie là était tout de suite
une maladie sociale c'est pas des
individus qui étaient malades qui sont
malades c'était des guides et des
communautés qu'il était et ça ça a été
vécu comme ça notamment grâce aux
activistes aux
organisations comme communautaire aux
organismes communautaires qui ont fait
effectivement qui ont mille sida comme
une question sociale et politique et pas
seulement comme une question purement
médicaux scientifiques et on la découvre
cette maladie en 1981 par un tout petit
article payant découvre cette maladie
mystérieuse entendent sais rien oui
exactement donc 5 juin 1981 l'acte ii
mais sa naissance scientifique du sida
sont effectivement lu communication dans
un bulletin technique très spécialisés
décide ici des centers for disease pour
l'américain ou un message aux médecins
d'ailleurs dit à los angeles j'ai eu
cinq cas bizarre de jeunes gens comme en
trente ans la trentaine qui était
normalement en bonne forme et qui ont
attrapé une maladie
une pneumonie une forme de pneumonie d'
extrêmement rare tellement rare
d'ailleurs qu'il faut commander le
traitement le médicament ou si d'ici
atlanta directement ça se trouve pas
dans la pharmacie du coin et c'est
bizarre on a sonne ils ont le système
immunitaire complètement
écroulé et la seule chose qu'on remarque
c'est que ce sont cinq jeunes
homosexuels actifs c'est tout ce qu'on
peut dire et donc c'est ça l'acte de
naissance et on parle on parle pas même
pas du du virus on sait pas il ya un
virus on n'imagine pas encore d'ailleurs
qui est nouveau virus ça doit être aussi
un choc pour les médecins qui sont
souvent jeunes je pense à réjean thomas
par exemple avec l'unique l'actuel qui
voit arriver dans sa dans un clinique de
jeunes patients qui sont des adultes qui
étaient en bonne santé et qui se
retrouvent avec une maladie terrible et
il m'a dit mystérieuse que personne ne
connait on a eu dans le cadre et jean
thomas c'est 1982 son premier patient
arrive en disant j'ai la maladie des
américains de confort mais parce que
c'était une maladie qui effectivement
toucher beaucoup les milieux
la communauté homosexuelle à new york et
en californie
il était devant des jeunes qui mouraient
et à qui on avait on pouvait rien faire
et ça c'était pour les médecins c'était
quelque chose très très dur ensuite
confronté à la mort parce que les gens
mouraient mouraient beaucoup
il n'y avait rien et on voit des
témoignages de ces patients qui sont
souvent un peu comme des vieillards et
qui ont sarcome de kaposi
tâche violations et c'est ça il y avait
2,2 maladie presque
typique du sida au début donc la fameuse
pneumonie à pneumocystis carnis des
lignes ont dû me trotte dans des
sciences et le sarcome de kaposi le
sarcome de kaposi c'est un cancer qu'on
voyait dans certaines régions d'afrique
et un peu exotique quand on a regardé
dans un grand hôpital adobe hôpital de
new york il ya vu cinq cas au cours des
trente dernières années toujours chez
les personnes âgées immuno supprimer ou
à peu près et donc menacer ces maladies
là qui arrive donc c'était vraiment
surprenant et donc le fameux sarcome de
kaposi tu m'as dit en plus qu'il faut
des tâches violacé sur le corps sous x
sur le visage et qui donnait une image
vraiment terrible du sida sida qui est à
ce moment là une maladie honteuse il n'y
a pas beaucoup de témoins parce que les
gens veulent pas expliquer ce qu'ils en
cash la maladie les maladies vénériennes
ou les infections transmises
sexuellement comme on dit aujourd'hui
ont souvent été appelé les maladies
honteuses et dans le cas du sida y avait
sa une
avait une prob comme disait jean thomas
mais il y avait deux chambres de malades
il y avait les les bons les pauvres les
hémophiles qui avait tranché où les
transfusés occasionnels qui ont été
victimes d'un accident puis avait les
méchants malades ceux qui étaient des
homosexuels qui étaient des utilisateurs
peuvent de drogues par voie
intraveineuse dont il y avait ces deux
ces deux images là mais oui c'était une
maladie qu'on cachait donc on voulait
pas les gens ne vais pas dire à la
télévision voilà j'ai le sida une des
entrevues qui moi m'avait marqué
beaucoup à l'époque parce que je
travaillais à toronto c'est celle de
notre ancien animateur luc hébert dont
qui donne une première et dernière
entrevue c'était un peu un choc
c'est le sarcome de kaposi donc si le
sida
j'éclate en sanglots
puis c'était extrêmement touchant parce
que c'était très rare de voir ce genre
d'entrevue j'ai l'impression que le
témoignage de luc hébert et c'est
peut-être la première fois où on voit en
gros plan à la télévision le visage du
sida de quelqu'un qui témoigne qui dit
on avait vu des images c'est mais en
français donc c'est une des premières
fois je pense et ça a été moins aussi
j'ai un souvenir très vif de cette image
là parce que ça a frappé tout à coup
quelqu'un disait voilà j'ai le sida il
expliqué
le cheminement de sa maladie et c'était
vraiment un et ça a été quelque chose
d'important parce que ç'a permis de de
montrer que le sida était aussi avait
aussi un visage humain le cas de roy 400
d'adelya des grandes vedettes quand même
qu'ils ont admis qu'ils avaient le sida
qui ont un peu changé la donne aussi qui
ont donné un peu une autre image maladie
tout à fait
jusqu'à 81 82 83 donc c'est la maladie
des autres
homosexuel avait dit des utilisateurs de
drogues par voie intraveineuse
c'est une maladie que monsieur madame
tout le monde ne peut pas attraper un
peu j med
simplifier un peu
4985 camp rock hudson annonce qu'il est
qui le sida il va mourir en octobre ne
soit 85 si vous n'irez bon c'est un peu
un choc sur roczen c'est une énorme
vedette d'hollywood dans des films dans
les séries télévision c'est l'image de
du séducteur et c'est de l'homme à
femmes bon et tout à coup il annonce son
orientation sexuelle ou fond et ça c'est
vraiment une sortie du placard comme on
dit extrêmement importante et ça montre
aussi effectivement que quelqu'un comme
lui comme une grande vedette peut être
touché et ça a touché beaucoup de temps
mais je pense que c'est un moment où
vraiment ça bascule en 2000 il ya un
autre visage aussi qu'il nous fera
beaucoup c'est l'image de ce jeune
garçon africain de 11 ans qui va
dénoncer la discrimination dont il est
victime parce qu'il est porteur du vih
et qui est un peu symbolise toute la
crise que vit l'afrique à ce moment là
c'est on est à conférence de durban
c'est la première fois que cet événement
médico scientifique au politico culturel
et dans les pays du sud et en afrique du
sud qui est particulièrement touchée et
à la cérémonie d'ouverture me souviens
on était
dizaines de milliers de personnes dans
le stade de cricket
il ya ce petit bonhomme
choisi john syndicaux jean johnson k 10
ans
non là avec sa cravate tout ce qui est
qui fait un discours des vraiment qu'ils
étaient magnifiques en disant nous
sommes nous aussi nous avons des besoins
en tout petit bonhomme de 11 ans qui va
mauvais d'ailleurs l'année d'après mais
c'était vraiment impressionnant et ça
symbolise eh oui le le drame de
l'afrique mais qu'on connaissait quand
même depuis une dizaine d'années
symbolisait aussi le fait qu'on peut
vivre avec le sida avoir le sida et est
quelqu'un et être un humain comme les
autres s'il avoue des mains des gens
comme vous
est ce que l'afrique à ce moment là
c'est l'apocalypse un peu on voit dans
les images de village où il ne reste que
des vieillards ou des orphelins de la
population adulte et 6 mai quand je suis
donc à durban en 2000 je suis allé aussi
à johannesbourg pour voir le sida non
pas dans la conférence mais dans la
population et il ya une jeune fait
même séropositive qui faisaient de la
l'action communautaire qui me dit si ça
continue et rapide jeunes et tous les
jours il ya des gens qui sont
diagnostiqués chez des jeunes et en
afrique traditionnellement d'expliquer
quelqu'un on mourait choix très jeunes
des maladies de la petite enfance choix
âgées comme tout le monde puis au milieu
il y avait des gens qui vivaient là
c'est le milieu qui tique et frapper les
gens meurent et y laissent leurs enfants
il ya le drame des orphelins du sida
c'était des millions d'enfants orphelins
du sida c'était vraiment un drame
terrible afrique et l'accès aux
médicaments étaient pas en 2011 que nul
de l'afrique alors qu'en 1996 arrive ce
fameux traitement à la trithérapie qui
va changer quand même la donne parce que
change la donne pour les gens si on le
peut avoir accès aux trithérapies qui
logent en général les gens et je
supporte bien se transforme en gros le
sida maladies chroniques les porteurs du
virus qui ont la trithérapie qui la
suivent bien et qui peuvent la suivre
ont une espérance de vie à peu près
semblable aux gens qui n'ont pas le
virus c'est incroyable donc on as en
1996 c'est comme un miracle et puis en
2000 on est toujours on n'a toujours pas
que ces médicaments n'a lui rien slogan
que lens et activiste est vraiment
extraordinaire les médicaments sont dans
le nord les patients sont dans le sud ça
dit tout à fait penser un peu à ce qui
se passe en ce moment c'est exactement m
jaune et donc les activistes en 2010 il
faut les médicaments doit les danseuses
les compagnies pharmaceutiques baume
doivent couper leurs prix donc en 2002
les scientifiques disent d'accord il
faut ça et en 2004 et ça c'est aussi
spécial particulier du site aérienne une
solidarité internationale qui monte on a
créé le fonds mondial de lutte contre le
sida la tuberculose et le paludisme qui
va récolter des milliards de dollars
pour pouvoir amener les trithérapies
dans le sud est c'est quand même quelque
chose qui s'est produit mais ça a pris
deux trois ans quatre ans pour que les
médicaments du nord avec dans le sud est
ni vous avez couvert cette maladie du
début jusqu'à aujourd'hui pratiquement
donc qu'est-ce que vous retenez parce
que votre lit s'appelle deuil donc on en
a parlé et la lumière pourquoi la
lumière de la lumière c'est c'est la
lumière qui apporte l'espoir les gens
n'ont jamais même dans les années les
plus sombres début des années 90
aucun médicament ne marchait rien on est
chauds terre à la grande déprime les
gens gardaient l'espoir et la volonté de
se battre ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'extraordinaire
le fait aussi que c'était de maladie
donc qui était vécue par des groupes par
des ensembles de madame par des
associations de malades ceci est
important et puis surtout la lumière
c'est aussi la lumière qu'apporte la
science m'excuse
important la trithérapie c'est un
produit de la découverte de la science
le troisième médicament chez lui qui va
faire la différence
c'est un médicament qui a été on a
découvert comment fonctionnait une en
gym en 86 87 on a travaillé pour
fabriquer deux molécules puis en 96 on
l'a eu en tout 95 dans la trithérapie
aussi quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est le 3tc médicaments inventé à
montréal développé à montréal qui est
encore utilisé aujourd'hui donc la
science la recherche scientifique et la
recherche clinique ont fait la
différence comme ce fait comme c'est le
cas avec l'aco vide
donc c'est ça la lumière s'allume hier
c'est c'est la lumière qu'apporte la
recherche scientifique la recherche
médicale c'est l'espoir merci beaucoup
yannick vous entrez